The Tasmanian devil is a carnivorous
marsupial, in fact it is the largest
living carnivorous marsupial in the world.
It is the top predator of Tasmania
and as a specialized scavenger also has
a recycling job
which is to clear, all day, dead
animals that are in the landscape.
So it has a very important ecological role
in keeping the ecosystem in a good balance.
Tasmanian devils are solitary, strictly
speaking they don't live
in groups or in family groups but
despite that they are quite social.
Quite social, but they're not that friendly
to each other so they can be
quite aggressive when having disputes
over meat for example, over food
so growling and biting is part of a normal Tasmanian devil's life.
The Tasmanian devils are affected by a very horrible disease called Devil Facial Tumour Disease
and this disease is characterised by large,
cancerous lesions that form around the
face and the neck of the affected devils.
The disease kills the
devils very quickly
and it's thought to have a hundred
percent mortality so it's had a
devastating effect on the population.
Devil Facial Tumour Disease
is a very strange and bizarre new type
of cancer
which has arisen recently in the Tasmanian devil population.
It's actually a cancer which is
transmissible, so it can be spread between devils.
These tumours were first seen by
a wildlife photographer in the far North East of Tasmania in 1996.
The disease turned up at my
long-term study site
on the Freycinet Peninsula on the East Coast of Tasmania in 2001.
Within 12 months of seeing the disease at my study site
I realised that it was both spreading and it was causing major population decline.